condenados a muerte por oponerse a un
golpe militar la junta gobernante de
mianmar anunció este lunes que había
ejecutado a cuatro activistas
prodemocráticos sus muertes las primeras
ejecuciones del país en décadas fueron
recibidas con una rápida condena por
parte de las organizaciones
internacionales de derechos humanos
desde square the s esto es claramente
una señal para el pueblo de mi alma por
parte de la junta de que están
preparados para hacer lo que sea
necesario cualquier abuso de los
derechos cualquier atrocidad cualquier
crimen que crean que tienen que hacer
para tratar de controlar la situación
ahora se están moviendo para ejecutar a
los presos políticos
ex grupo de personas
entre los asesinados kojima de 53
veterano de las revueltas estudiantiles
de 1988 contra la anterior dictadura
militar ya había cumplido múltiples
condenas de prisión por su activismo
dios y ella top por su parte era un
antiguo activista de hip hop de 41 años
que se había convertido en legislador
del partido liga nacional de la
democracia dirigido por avanzan sus y
sus y fue destituida por un golpe de
estado militar en febrero de 2021 tras
obtener una victoria aplastante en las
elecciones generales
ella misma se enfrenta ahora a cargos
que podrían suponer una condena de 150
años de prisión los cuatro condenados
fueron declarados culpables de cargos de
terrorismo en tribunales militares a
puerta cerrada el pasado mes de enero la
junta ha defendido sus acciones
calificando de imprudentes e
injerencistas las protestas
internacionales por sus ejecuciones tras
el golpe de estado del año pasado las
fuerzas de seguridad utilizaron munición
real para aplastar las protestas en su
mayoría pacíficas y se calcula que más
de 2.000 civiles murieron en la
represión